hi I'm Eric Voss and black panther's
finally here and as always there are
some post-credit scenes that rolled
after the film this case they present
some interesting connections to the
upcoming Avengers infinity war and yes
you may be getting this video a little
early before maybe you've had a chance
to see the movie so spoiler warning in
case you haven't seen the movie yet you
can always pause this video and then go
watch it and come back for an
explanation of what it all means
right oh wait Oh back so soon Wow okay
let's get started there were two scenes
a mid-credits scene and a post-credits
scene the first shows T'Challa
joined by Nakia in a Koi a speaking in
front of a UN conference announcing that
what kind of will now share their
knowledge and resources with the world
and no longer watch from the shadows
with an isolationist philosophy and said
looking at other nations as brothers and
sisters as if they were a part of one
single tribe and then another UN
delegate scoffs asking what remote
nation of farmers could offer and
T'Challa his delegation and ever draw
just smile knowingly so we actually saw
footage of this scene in the trailers it
was originally planned to be part of the
ending of the movie but director Ryan
Coogler said that he moved it to the mid
credit spot for symmetry reasons this
allowed him to make the film's real
ending more emotionally resonance while
keeping this view in seen as sort of an
epilogue now the scene cuts off before
T'Challa explains exactly what resources
what kind of can offer the world like
super advanced vibranium based
technology and sick wrist beads and make
the iPhone look like a poop tart but
essentially this speech seems like it's
meant to evoke Tony Stark's coming out
at the end of Ironman without saying it
explicitly T'Challa looks ready to
announce with the smirk on Black Panther
but I guess in this case the reporters
and UN delegates would be like okay cool
we still don't totally know what that
means oh you're still kind of an unknown
to the outside world but we look forward
to getting oh yeah really it was the
second post-credits scene that presented
the bigger questions the second end
credits scene features a cameo by Bucky
Barnes the Winter Soldier recovering in
a wakandan village as Sheree tells him
come much more for you to learn now this
isn't too surprising earlier in the
movie sure he did refer to Ross as
another broken white boy for us to fix
hinting at Bucky whom we know from the
post-credits scene after Captain America
Civil War that he was recovering in
secret in Wakanda
also the footage for the upcoming
Avengers infinity war has shown Bucky
with a new vibranium look
armed fighting against the outriders in
that big battle scene set in Wakanda but
really the cool detail about the scene
are the wakandan kids who look down at
Bucky at the top of the scene they run
out of his Hut shouting the white wolf
interesting so in the Marvel Comics
White Wolf is a supporting character in
the Black Panther world he was a white
guy adopted by two challahs father -
Chaka growing up as hunter he led the
covert ops war dogs group of Wakanda now
this could mean Marvel is merging
Bucky's character with Hunter these kind
of tweaks from the comics have been done
by Marvel in the past or these kids
could be confusing Bucky with another
dangerous white man living in their
country suggesting the white wolf is a
separate character in the MCU that we
have yet to see perhaps in some future
black panther sequel black panther and
white wolf the new Thor and Hulk of the
MCU I guess or for that matter the new
Deadpool and cables since Disney owns
all this crap now they take away for
both of these post credits scenes is
that the world of Black Panther is
opening up to the broader MCU with
Wakanda technology now being shared to
arm the rest of Earth's Mightiest Heroes
for win purple Bruce Willis comes
looking for its jewelry I mean that's
pretty much what I'm finna be Wars gonna
be right but a question I want to throw
to you guys does Black Panther as a
movie really need to join the broader
MCU narrative or do you think this
character in the world would work better
as its own side narrative you comment
with your thoughts down below or tweet
me directly I da boss and follow new
rockstars on Twitter at new rockstars
for updates on our videos and of course
subscribe to new rockstars for deep
dives into everything black panther
related our review of the movie and an
upcoming in-depth breakdown and
everything you missed and all the big
details you need to know on the upcoming
Avengers infinity war and if you really
love us and you want to help us grow you
can contribute to this channel on
patreon a big thanks to all of our
donors especially Kelly hopper thanks
for watching guys bye